Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this week on
Orphan Black Doctor Leekie and Sarah both
dropped
huge bombs about the original cloning experiment.
A bunch of people seem like they’re changing
their allegiances and we got to see some very
pretty dirty sexy Rachel.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I usually do weekly Orphan Black videos, be
sure to subscribe to get everything.
I missed last week so there’s no episode
4 video but feel free to leave questions about
anything from the last couple of episodes
in the comments.
So where do we start.
This episode was filled with a lot of WTF
moments that made me laugh a little.
I’m not sure what you’d call that.
But here are my top 5.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
Number 5 - Paul Becomes Rachel’s New Daniel
Turns out that’s a pretty demanding job.
I love the power dynamic in all of Rachel’s
relationships, not just the sexual relationships.
It’s like any room she walks in to she just
dominates.
Unless she’s with Sarah and then there’s
always this weird vibe.
Just because I think Rachel is a little afraid
of her.
Maybe of Helena too.
It really seemed like Rachel was having fun
trying to take Sarah’s toy.
Toy being Paul.
Maybe that’s just a sister joke.
It’s fun to watch her be petty since she’s
always so hard to read.
I couldn’t really tell what Paul’s motivations
in all this are.
It seems like he’s going to the darkside
and Rachel is the Emperor.
In all fairness, if the Emperor in Star Wars
looked like Rachel, there would have been
a lot more people trying to join the Sith.
Number 4 - Paul Incriminates Felix To Blackmail
Sarah
I loved how this went from really sweet, to
funny, to scary so fast.
Felix gets his crazy date night montage with
Colin and the one thing he promised wouldn’t
happen happens and the police burst in.
Just as Colin squeezes like the entire tube
out on his hand.
The look on his face was priceless.
What this, this is nothing.
And then for just a minute I really thought
Rachel had sent Paul to kill Felix.
But it’s all about blackmailing Sarah.
It hasn’t worked yet, so as of the end of
the episode.
Felix is rotting in jail.
That whole sequence of events was so crazy
you could really pick any one of the moments
out as a favorite, but the actors talked about
how hard it was for them to film the gun scene.
Let me know if you think Paul really would
kill Felix or one of the other non-clone friends.
I don’t think Rachel would kill any of the
core clones.
It was kind of implied that he killed some
people for her in Taiwan.
It’s hard to tell when Rachel was looking
at him when she first told him she was taking
him along.
I thought she either took him for security
or sex.
Or both.
I really do like the way Rachel is blurring
the lines with Paul.
It’s funny when they invoke Daniel in their
dirty pretty sexy time.
Number 3 - Doctor Leekie Likes Beer
I’m so happy with the way allegiances are
changing.
Leekie is best buds with clone club or anything,
but he is making them a deal.
At the end of the day I think he just wants
to push his project forward and he’s willing
to help Sarah and the Clones if it means they
can recover lost data.
There was so much information that got dropped
in Cosima’s scenes.
Leekie is searching for the synthetic DNA
inside the clones that’s keeping them alive.
My guess is that they won’t be able to cure
whatever is making Cosima sick until they
find Rachel’s Father and get whatever Data
he has.
I’m also totally expecting Leekie to double
cross clone club again.
If he’s lying to Rachel to help Cosima,
then why wouldn’t he just turn around and
lie to Cosima at some point.
Let me know if you think he’ll keep helping
them after he gets what he needs.
That will be the test.
Number 2 - The Creator Is Still Alive
One of their creators that is.
But it looks like Swan Man, Rachel’s father
is alive and hiding out somewhere.
Helena is like the world’s best bloodhound.
If the pacing of the last couple of episodes
holds up, they’ll probably find him in the
next 1 or 2 episodes.
Basically all the hard data is supposed to
have been lost in the fire.
The original genome they developed to grow
the clones.
So they can’t grow more or fix the clones
that are breaking down, until they learn more
about it.
And right now it seems like Swan Man is the
only one who can help.
I’m wondering how Mrs S is connected to
him too.
She’s in her 50s and Swan Man is supposed
to be in his 70s.
So maybe she was just like a lab tech or an
intern working with them.
Or she was related to one of them.
But I love that were getting so much new information
about the original cloning experiment.
It’s like they’re teasing a prequel show
for when Orphan Black goes off the air.
It would be like baby Clone Club set in the
70s.
and my Number 1 moment - Sarah Stops Helena
from Killing Rachel
I actually thought this moment was more intense
than Felix with the gun.
Mostly because Sarah stepped in front of the
sniper rifle while she was trying to talk
Helena down.
All while Rachel was mauling Paul.
She’s so fascinating.
It’s like she’s using weird sex as a way
to let her emotions out.
And Paul is like a new race horse she’s
thinking about buying, so she just inspects
him like an animal.
That was pretty epic as far as sex scenes
go.
How amazing was Helena too.
She was by far my favorite Clone this week.
I can’t get Pretty, Dirty, Sexy out of my
head.
And that doll.
All of that was why I laughed so hard when
Sarah threatened Leekie at the bar later.
I love the dynamic between Helena and Sarah.
It’s like they’re a separate two-member
Clone Club inside the larger Clone Club because
they were born as twins.
Helena acknowledges she has other seestra’s,
but I think Sarah is the only one she’s
bonded to.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite moment was.
And which sex scene did you think was the
funniest.
I don’t mean intentionally funny, I just
mean the one you laughed at the most.
Overall the episode was a solid B plus.
I always get excited when the writers flip
a bunch of the relationships on the show.
Leekie helping the clones, Paul letting himself
get dominated by Rachel.
Like I said, my favorite clone this week was
Helena.
Rachel was fascinating, but this week Helena
was like a black hole for my attention.
Just so strong I couldn’t think about anything
else when she was around.
You really do forget sometimes that Tatiana
Maslany is playing them all.
There’s only so many times you can say she’s
amazing until we all just accept it as something
that will always be the same.
Of all the characters right now I feel like
Felix and Paul are the weakest, Felix gets
physically dominated for comedy a lot, but
Paul is like a Robot that Sarah and Rachel
are controlling.
I think Paul thinks he’s doing everything
for the greater good.
But really at the end of the day he has no
will of his own.
He’s just an appendage of Rachel’s now.
An appendage she likes to have sex with in
really strange ways.
I can’t wait till we get an extended scene
with Rachel and Helena though.
They’re like the two heavy hitters on the
show right now.
Not to forget any of the other important plot
points.
Some of these are interesting and some are
just horrifying.
First Gracie in the torture closet.
She is not going to walk away from this season
with all her marbles.
The Proletheans are just way too crazy to
let anyone stay sane.
Most importantly, she’s probably going to
end up having to carry that creepy baby.
As nuts as she is, how can you not feel bad
for her.
Kira and Cal are adorable together, but we
keep seeing Kira’s supernatural qualities
manifest, like she’s playing a different
game from everyone else.
She’s so self aware it’s unsettling.
Like when Cal is making jokes about socks
and she’s scanning money, passports and
guns.
And then there’s Cosima’s sickness she’s
been hiding from the rest of the Clones.
Sarah understands what’s going on but with
Allison in rehab it seems like Clone Club
is slowly coming apart at the seams.
I’m really excited to find out what the
Place of Screams is next week though.
I have a wedding I have to go to but I’m
still going to be doing a few bonus videos
next weekend.
I’ll try to get Orphan Black up too.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ll be posting updates on social.
Right now click here for my last Orphan Black
video and click here to learn all about the
new Grant Gustin Flash TV Show.
I’m really excited about it.
Thanks so much for watching, high fives everyone,
see you tomorrow!